pour le calvados je trouve le résultat
que j'ai eue pour concernant les
estimations de participation sont très
favorables donc l'électorat s'est
mobilisé c'est parfait voilà chacun a pu
insérer le bulletin de vote de son choix
donc c'est très bien dans ce cas de
figure d'une participation un peu
meilleur que attendus pour ce ça peut
profiter au front national
peut-être je sais pas j'ai pas encore
assez de recul pas suffisamment de
résultats pour pour le dire mais pas
encore de tendance ici ou là qu'il
pourrait non non non pas suffisamment
qu'est-ce-qui qu'elle peut être
l'objectif que vous vous fixez sur sur
la région chose département l'objectif
bien entendu était quand même d'être ans
minimum en seconde position
maintenant nous verrons selon les
cantons parce que les électeurs ont
décidé vous attendez une progression
importante
déjà nous n'étions pas présents au
départemental précédente sur tous les
cantons
donc le fait que nous soyons présents
aujourd'hui sur tous les cantons
effectivement c'est une c'est une bonne
poussée vos candidats ont dû le temps de
s'implanter de prendre et faire
connaissance des électeurs parce que le
parti va vraiment sur le terrain depuis
exactement
donc ce n'était pas une élection facile
pour nous puisque le calvados commence
seulement à émerger
quel serait pour vous un succès dans le
département
d'avoir des conseillers départementaux
bien entendu mais ceci dit je remercie
d'ailleurs nos électeurs qui se sont
très bien mobilisé d'après les premiers
résultats que je peux avoir
et donc nous verrons quand nous aurons
tous les résultats
certains on sort du 1er tour on pense
aussi au deuxième tour vous avez déjà
une consigne que vous avez à circuler
aucune consigne de vote c'est vivre tout
à fait nos électeurs sont des personnes
grand des responsables dont kiel avec
décideront eux mêmes
est ce que vous pouvez dire que
quelqu'un qui allait voter au premier
tour doit aller voter au deuxième tour
ils choisissent effectivement le vote
nous avons le droit de vote donc pour
moi c'est une obligation
on doit se rendre aux urnes maintenant
si nos électeurs nous estime que dans le
choix qu'ils auront ils ne se
reconnaissent pas c'est eux qui décident